foreign
Alabama let's check in with Facebook
looks like we've got a question here
from Jay what's the difference between
clinging to someone versus having a
Sentimental attachment to them well
clinging is what happens when you can't
let go and so it's different from
holding on I like to think of when my
daughter is on the monkey bars it's a
constant practice of holding on and
letting go holding on and letting go
because if you can't let go you can't
move on but also if you can't hold on
you also can't move forward and so when
we get to Jay's the essence of Jay's
question here
clinging to someone versus having a
Sentimental attachment to them
well attachment is ultimately clinging
if you can't let go and so it's not that
every attachment is a type of clinging
but if you're unable to let go of that
attachment well you're clinging and you
you just gotta loosen the grip
as humans
we attach we need relationships we
actually need love and part of the
reason that I talk about love is an
addictive process in this book is
because love is actually a drive it is a
biological need in us and from Early
Childhood
you need adults to take care of you to
feed you clothe you be sure you're safe
and essentially that makes you attached
to them that is a need and so as you get
older and you bring that learning into
your adult relationships
when you're in a healthy romantic
relationship you want to be attached to
your partner it's a very positive thing
to be attached to your partner
clinging to me sounds like you're not
really that attached or they maybe don't
want to be attached to you and so you're
holding on sort of Desperately to
something that isn't secure
that can put you in a very precarious
emotional position and so I would say to
anyone who feels like they're clinging
on to something it's not fully stable
probably and so work to figure out if
you can make it stable or if perhaps you
really need to cut the cord here and
move forward
hmm
yeah I uh I think it's weird that they
said sentimental so what I heard the way
I heard you reframe the question was how
do I know the difference between
clinging and clinging is the way I heard
you basically rephrase that but they use
the word sentimental which to me um
means something that we hold on to
because of a memory with it or we hold
on to it because of a uh just a a habit
that we have always had this thing in
our life or in this case this person in
our life and for me like that Roots back
to certainty and we all want some kind
of certainty
um yeah I mean
I I don't think I would never recommend
anyone cling to anything but if you're
clinging to something at the cost of
living a less meaningful life uh than if
you weren't clinging into that thing I
mean that is maybe where they need the
um the discernment here of like okay
like I know I have this person in my
life I'm cleaning them I need them to be
in my life I mean that's okay it doesn't
sound like you said like the most stable
situation but ask yourself like what
does it look like without that person in
your life I mean you could even do this
with your things what you know I got
this Stein my grandma gave me from high
school that sentimental to me like I can
think about what what happened in my
life if I let go of that sign and it
disappeared I'd be okay like I'd be
totally fine with it so maybe that's the
question they need to ask themselves
yeah I see clinging as kind of like
being dishonest with myself about the
direction in which the energy of life is
taking me and I think doctor gave us the
imagery where clinging is something is
moving away from me and I'm trying to
keep it just a little bit longer or my
life is moving me away from it and I'm
not being honest about the inevitability
of what's Happening Here and so I cling
and that clinging produces anxiety and
stress and insecurity it's unhealthy
because I'm not being honest about the
fact that they don't want to be with me
or this moment of life is over or it's
time for me to graduate and move on to
something new whereas The Nostalgia the
sentimental longing for something is
just a way of saying hey this made an
impression on me and it lives in me in
some sense forever and that's okay as
long as I can let go of what that was
circumstantially yeah did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free